good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker
dr russ poldrack the albert ray lang
professor of psychology
and professor of computer science at
stanford university
dr paul drake completed his bachelor's
degree in psychology from baylor
university in 1989
and his phd in experimental psychology
from the university of illinois at
urbana-champaign in 1995 working closely
with neil j
cullen from 1995 to 1999 he was a
postdoctoral fellow at stanford
university working closely with john
gabrielli
in his professional experience prior to
his appointment at stanford in 2014 he
held faculty positions at harvard
medical school
at ucla and at the university of texas
at austin
he has been the pi on numerous nih
funded and nsf funded grants in brain
research the modeling of cognitive
ontologies
as well as the fields of
neuroinformatics and data science
he's been awarded a distinguished
scientific
award in early career contributions to
psychology from the american
psychological association
he was awarded the wiley young
investigator award from the organization
for human brain mapping in 2005 and is a
fellow of the association for
psychological sciences
elected in 2009. he's also served as the
chairperson of the organization for
human brain mapping he is the founder
and co-editor
of the uh frontiers in brain imaging
methods
and he was the chair of the external
advisory panel for the human connectome
project and a member of advisory panels
for
the adolescent brain and cognitive
development study as well as the
the kavli human study the work from his
laboratory involves functional
neuroimaging
the study of learning and memory
executive function decision making
uh the notions of reverse
inference as well as the pursuits
in neuroinformatics data science data
sharing and
reproducible and responsible science his
lecture today is entitled towards a
culture
of computational reproducibility and as
always we are streaming this
lecture live uh and for recording via
youtube and if you're watching on
youtube
thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr poldrack by the chat feature in
your zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of dr paul drax's
lecture
and with that welcome russ thank you so
much we are really looking forward to
your lecture
all right well thanks very much for the
invitation happy to be here
and hello to everybody on youtube um so
i want to talk today about kind of
moving towards a
culture of reproducibility and when i
talk about reproducibility
i'm primarily focusing on what people
often refer to as computational
reproducibility
um you know this is ping's kind of
spectrum of reproducibility on
on the one hand you have kind of you
know like full replication like a new
study
new data um i'm going to focus on
kind of just before that the idea of you
know kind of sharing everything that
goes into an analysis and simply being
able
to reproduce the results that one finds
not
now obviously you know in the end we
want to be able to generalize out to new
data
and and new you know new analysis code
as well and i'll talk some about that
but
the the point here i want to make here
is i'm really focusing on
reproducibility as sort of
um not quite all the way to replication
but simply taking a
a completed study and you know showing
that we can reproduce the results
now um you know a lot of my thinking is
inspired by this
quote from david donahoe a statistician
here at stanford he was really one of
the pioneers of
kind of reproducible data science who
said an article about a computational
result is advertising not scholarship
the actual scholarship is the full
software environment code and data that
produce the result
so why is this a problem well
you know first in many different domains
data analysis
today is highly complex and offers an
extreme degree of flexibility in the way
that one can do one analyses
and it's generally impossible to
reproduce a result
just using the publication and even with
the code and the data
it can be different difficult to
reproduce the results so i want to sort
of talk through an example of this
from a study that i did a few years ago
this was a study where i had scanned
myself repeatedly over the course of a
year and a half
collected you know blood data did rna
sequencing
and then we published a paper where we
tried to build a reproducible analysis
workflow
and we did this using a technology
called virtual machines which is
basically building sort of a
a little computer inside a computer that
should look exactly the same way for
anybody who runs it
and so we gave this out and basically
said hey if you run this thing
uh you install it in your computer and
run it you know it'll take a few hours
and ultimately you'll have all the same
results that we
used in the that we report in the paper
so i get an email maybe a year later
hi i'm an undergraduate student johns
hopkins i'm trying to you know
reproduce your results i've run into
some trouble reproducing the rna seek
results
there's supposed to be 63 coexpression
modules but when i run the scripts
i only get 60. i reran the analysis with
the vm and the real
result is 60. um essentially the same
code is run on the same data but arrives
at two different results what might be
going on
and it turns out that if you look at the
version of the
r package that we used to do that
analysis in the paper it was 1.47
by the time you know he went to run the
analysis it was version 1.51 and it
turns out that our virtual machine
pulled the latest version of the code
and that
little change from 1.747 to 1.51
resulted
in differences in the results of the
analysis
even though we had this like fully
reproducible in theory
uh analysis platform we also know that
you know
small differences can actually have
impact on analysis results this is some
work from tristan guitard a few years
ago showing that
if you run free surfer on
on structural imaging data you can get
different results either between
different linux versions or even between
different software builds
which they ultimately track down a
particular numeric libraries
um so that's that's one sort of set of
concerns around
uh you know the platform dependence and
the version dependence of
results another has to do with software
errors so
um you know much of what we do as
scientists is really amateur software
engineering right and the question is
how likely are we to make errors if you
look at professional software developers
on their first submission of code they
across studies make anywhere from 150
errors per thousand of lines of code
so how many errors do we think we make
as amateur software developers
and how likely are they to impact our
scientific conclusions well we know
of examples where this has happened one
comes from the work of jeffrey chang he
was a structural biologist who published
a bunch of papers in the early 2000s
about this particular protein the abc
transporter
and um ended up having to retract
five papers because um there was a piece
of code that they used they'd actually
gotten from someone else
that ended up causing a sign flip that
caused the wrong handedness of the
protein structures
and a particular concern is you know
what some of us have started calling
bug hacking which is the idea that
when you know bugs aren't neutral
in terms of you know our likelihood of
finding them right
if we have a bug that disconfirms our
predictions it gives us results that we
quote unquote don't like we're much more
likely to dig in and sort of find that
bug than
if we have a bug that gives us the
results that we're expecting or sort of
gives us results that are better than
they actually
should be so i'm going to argue
that we need to develop a culture of
computational reproducibility that
everything that we do needs to be sort
of
focused on how we can do science that's
computationally reproducible and i'm i'm
going to lay this out
in terms of an idea that that was
inspired by reading
kent beck's work on extreme programming
where he talks about a culture of
of you know software development um and
so that
which it sort of frames it around the
idea of values principles and practices
so what
and um this this idea of culture is also
you know sort of highlighted in the the
work but from the national academies a
couple years ago where they said
recommendation number one
research institute should work to create
a culture that actively supports open
science by design
and reproducibility is part of that so
what are these values that i talk about
well the first should be
objectivity right which basically means
we want to get the answers right and one
objectivity is a complex concept in the
philosophy of science and one
one way that i like that people talk
about it is in terms of minimizing what
you might think of as
epistemic risk the risk of having
incorrect
knowledge um another value is community
you know we think that
science should be a communal rather than
a competitive endeavor
third is respect that the community
should be open and inclusive and respect
the
contributions and positionality of each
individual
fourth is humility we have to
acknowledge the fact that we're humans
and everything we do has biases and
limitations and then there's also
constraints on the generality of our
work
fifth value is openness our work should
be available to others to
reproduce and use and um six is
transparency our work should be clear
and understandable to others so then the
question is
how do we turn those values into
principles
um now you might be asking why is he
talking about
like you know openness and inclusivity
here and you know there are clearly
humanistic reasons that you know that we
want to be
open and inclusive and diverse but
there's also
good reasons from the philosophy of
science and this is
um a quote from helen longino who's a
feminist philosopher of science who has
laid out this argument that you know why
does
why does science work right um and one
of her arguments is that science works
exactly because it's a social phenomenon
that
takes ideas and puts them up to scrutiny
and so this is a quote from her when
background assumptions are shared by all
members of a community
they acquire an invisibility that
renders them but unavailable for
criticism they don't become visible
until
individuals who don't share the
community's assumptions can provide
alternative explanations of phenomena
without those assumptions
as for example einstein could provide an
alternative explanation of the
michaelson morley interferometer
experiment
because he didn't share the assumption
of the variable speed of light
from all this again it follows that the
greater the number of different points
of view included in a given community
the more likely it is that scientific
practice will be objective
and results in descriptions and
explanations of natural processes that
are more reliable than would otherwise
be the case
okay so what are the principles that
we're going to
use to kind of you know guide the
practices well one is going to be
diversity we want a
community to be as diverse inclusive and
equitable as possible
we're going to build around community
standards we need we want our work to be
structured by
a common understanding of what best
practices are
we want to sort of highlight the role of
reflection on our on our own practices
so following feynman's quote that the
first principle is that you must not
fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
and i'm going to focus on the idea of
errors as sort of the best learning
experiences
um fourth principle is continuous
improvement the idea that
you know that everything we do but
particularly software development is a
skill
that we have to continuously and
deliberately hone
and fifth is a principle of portability
the idea that
any analysis should be repeatable at
different times across different systems
you can think of reproducibility at some
in some way as like you know portability
in time
so finally i'm going to i'm going to
walk through a set of practices and this
is going to be the meat of the talk
i'm going to first talk about how
building and nurturing a community
second about how coding for
reproducibility
third about sharing and openness and
forth about automation
so first building a community um
so you know everybody talks about how
they want to collaborate but um
there's more to collaboration than
simply you know sort of exchanging
knowledge and having a common goal
across teams and this is a
illustration from the touring way which
is a really nice
project from the alan turing institute
that lays out a bunch of you know
thoughts about
how to build open inclusive diverse
collaborative teams i i definitely would
would recommend having a look at that
resource um
so the one of the important aspects of
building an
open community is making it clear how
people can become a part of the
community and contribute um and and one
of the things one can do there is
giving out guidelines to so this is an
example of
for our fmri prep project which is a
data pre-processing workflow for for
fmri data
we lay out uh basically you know
one why you know how can somebody
contribute why should they contribute
and then
get a lot of details about the specific
ways in which you know a person can go
about
contributing um and you know really
trying to make the project as
as open and inviting as possible to
anybody with any set of skills
you know making it clear you don't have
to be like a you know a super expert
coder to contribute
second is codes of conduct making it
clear that you know we want to build a
community that's opening
open and welcoming to everybody
and that's harassment free and so this
is our fm right prep code of conduct
there's a lot of you know various codes
of conduct that are available out there
to kind of uh
to crib from and that's what we did here
but just basically making it clear what
do you what are you expected to
how are you expected to behave as part
of this community now you know a lot of
these practices have been put in place
in hackathons and you know hackathons
are common in lots of different
areas you know i have experience with
the ones in neuroscience in particular
the brain hack which has been you know
held around the um
the ohvm meeting for the last few years
um cameron craddock has you know has
been one of the the main organizers
along here belleck and others and has
written
a paper recently about this idea um and
really you know what they do is they
try to bring people in through
educational experiences and get them
involved in community through
you know working together on hacking
projects and this is kirsty whitaker
having a lot of fun at
the brain hack a couple years ago um
so so i think that you know the the
brain engine community is uh
has given us like a really nice example
of like how
this sort of like open science
community that's kind of you know
diverse and open and welcoming
can actually work and so i definitely
would would
invite all of you to take part actually
brain hack global is happening right now
so um so i don't know like you can
probably still sort of get involved in
it
but certainly in the future you know
becoming involved in hackathons is a
great way to
sort of start working to build this
community
all right so now let's talk about how to
code for reproducibility
um and um there's a number of features
that are important for writing high
quality code
right one is that it needs to be
readable
um and i'll talk more about this second
is it needs to be robust
it needs to you know run across
different platforms and get the same
answer it needs to be modular
uh both for reusability and also for
easier testability and finally it needs
to be well tested
and i want to highlight the fact that
you know coding is a craft
right many people have hobbies you know
i play guitar
and the only way you get better at
playing guitar is by practicing
similarly the only way you get better at
coding is by
consistent and deliberate practice and
this is highlighted in the fact that you
know the software carpentry
sort of uses this analogy directly right
that
uh we you need to uh you need to to
practice the skills just as you would if
you're going to become a carpenter
so it turns out that there's you know a
good bit that's known from
software engineering about you know how
to build better software
so you know what what's striking is you
know even in commercial software
development
about 40 to 50 and this is written a few
years ago i don't know if these numbers
have changed a lot they probably have
with the advent of of better software
engineering practices
um about 40 to 50 of the effort
is spent on avoidable rework this is
professional software developers during
development almost no modules are defect
free as they've been implemented and
post release
this is after they've been reviewed
about
40 percent of modules may be defect-free
that meaning the majority of them still
have defects peer reviews can catch
about 60 of the defects and discipline
disciplined personal practices can
reduce defect rates by up to 75 percent
so what are some of those practices well
the first that
you know that i think everybody should
be using and most of you are probably
familiar with is version control
if you have programmed without using
version control you're probably
accustomed to seeing file names like
this
where you basically have embedded the
version control in the file name
version control you know using tools
like git and github provides a
a much better way to to track
what's been done with code it also
provides a really nice
and and easy way to experiment using
branches
and so if you're not familiar with git i
would suggest maybe starting with
the um the software carpentry uh modules
on
on git and github which are really nice
um another thing that i think gets less
you know many people are familiar with
version control i think many few people
or many fewer people are familiar with
coding style um
and coding style is really important
because you know as the founder of
python guida van rossum said
code is read much more often than it's
written
so readability counts um now nearly
every language has a language specific
convention for coding style
and following those conventions makes
your code easier for others to read and
understand and it's important to
keep in mind that others includes your
future self right when you look back at
code six months from now
it's as if you are a different person
and so if the code is readable you'll be
you'll be much more easily able to
figure out what on earth was i
trying to do there now there's also
a lot of sort of language independent
principles of software design i'm
showing a few of the books here that
that i found useful um i think as a
starting point
this book called the art of readable
code um
is probably a great starting point for
just learning sort of language
independent principles of
how to how to write good code that may
focus a lot on kind of making it
understandable
now you know we mentioned the idea that
uh
code review can find lots of bugs
and this sort of fits with linus's law
from linus torvald given enough eyeballs
all bugs are shallow right if enough
people look at code
um the bugs are going to pop out to
somebody
and so the idea of code review for
scientific code has been around for a
long time
petrie and wilson wrote about this you
know a number of years ago
but i think there's increasing interest
recently
you know there's just a twitter thread a
couple days ago about this with a number
of people chiming in about
how they've started implementing this
you know in their labs
but this paper lays out kind of some
nice ideas about how to implement this
we've started implementing code review
regularly in our lab meetings
roughly once a month we take somebody's
code and sort of walk through it and do
a review
um so another you know important thing
that i think gets less
notice in scientific code is testing
so any function that does something
important
should be tested one it should make sure
that you know
you know what the code should do and you
want to write tests that make sure it
does the things properly
you also want to make sure that like in
the
in the occasions when the code should
like you know raise an error that it
actually does that right that it doesn't
sort of just give you
you know garbage out for garbage in now
most languages have powerful
testing frameworks you know i'm familiar
with the ones in python and r
um martin fowler who's you know the
one of the kind of you know deans of
software engineering says whenever
you're tempted to type something into a
print statement or a debugger expression
write it as a test instead and we
we often in my lab try to use something
there's an idea called test driven
development and we don't do this
kind of you know kind of rigorously but
the idea is like
if you want to know if something's
working rather than kind of you know
just like trying it out on your
on your own typing it into your to your
console just build a test every time you
want to check that something is working
build a new test for it
use the test framework and then you'll
have those tests around as you add new
features to make sure that you haven't
broken anything
now a corollary to this is that whenever
there are well-established libraries to
do something you should use them
engineers often get sort of sucked in by
this thing that people refer to as the
nih of the not invented here effect
in which they they think that they need
to build a new solution
that's homegrown rather than use an
existing solution and my favorite
example of this is the
the large number of dicom to nifty
converters that exist in the neural
imaging field
so you know whenever there's an existing
package it's much better to
use that package and if you need to add
features
contribute fixes or extensions to that
existing package
you know become part of that development
community rather than trying to roll
your own
um and you also want to prefer libraries
that use good software engineering
practices that have
you know and this is sort of seen for
example in scikit-learn
through all the you know the badges like
the fact that it has 96
code coverage 96 of the code is being
tested it's passing
various versions of python for example
um
so testing is a deep rabbit hole but
there's some pretty simple things one
can do
the simplest is assertions basically
just making sure that
if some if you know something to be true
make sure it's true
um here's an example of a case where
that could have saved somebody a good
bit of pain this was a paper that was
published in plos one
they shared their data because you have
to with plus one and somebody
realized after looking at the data hey
there's uh this is supposed to be data
from adults
there's two subjects one with age five
one with age three two seven
five seven and um that when you fix
those that changes the results
um had they simply you know put in an
assertion saying hey we need to assert
that
the age is between say you know six and
120
that would have caught that issue
now we also want to make sure that our
code is actually giving us the right
answer
and you know before so to validate code
a couple things to think about are one
what we call parameter recovery which is
basically
before you ever analyze real data
analyze
you know generate some synthetic data um
where you know what the answer should be
and make sure that your code can recover
the known answer
um like i said best to do that before
you ever touch the real data
the other is null or randomization
testing where you generate data where
you know that there's no effect
either by you know synthetic data or by
randomizing real data
and make sure that you're that your
analysis says hey there's no effect
here's a place where that might have
been useful so this was a paper
published a few years ago claiming to
have you know very high accuracy in a
very small sample
of decoding you know different uh
classes
of uh of cognitive impairment
using diffusion imaging so they turns
out that they
what they did they did a feature
selection step
prior to cross validation which
we know to be problematic it's sort of
basically kind of a double dipping
you're using the data to
pick the best features and then using
those features to actually do your cross
validation
this is a simulation that i ran showing
basically
what happens you know what is accuracy
when you do
feature selection within the cross
validation which comes out here you know
right around point five on average
when you do the feature selection and
then do cross validation
you get accuracy so often perfect or you
know
around point nine um so basically just
you know
had they done some simple simulations to
look at the effect of their
um of their procedures they would have
seen hey this is
really problematic um so
you know despite all of our best efforts
we're going to make errors in our code
and so what matters is how we respond to
them
when we discover them so we had an issue
recently where we had
we've done a large analysis of the abcd
data set the behavior
on the data set identified some issues
with the stop signal data
made our code available with the with
the preprint
and the abcd team dug into this and
realized we had made an error
in the code in this like really complex
boolean operation
and when we fixed it it changed the
numbers it didn't change the overall
kind of take away the paper but it
definitely changed the numbers in the
paper
um so what we did was um
you know we obviously we fixed the the
preprint um
and the code but we also tried to use
this error as a teachable moment
taking as a model this idea of the
morbidity and mortality conference which
is something that's done regularly at um
academic medical centers where um
basically
the idea is not to criticize but to
profit from sharing and examining
experience in a blame-free environment
focusing on
either like poor intended outcomes that
might have been due to due to or
worsened by
error or system problems or talking
about near misses where something
bad almost happened and importantly
there's no finger pointing right it's
really figuring out
how do you how might you fix the causes
rather than
kind of focusing on the errors that
people made in particular focusing on
sort of
the root causes right so when we've done
this
thinking through you know thinking about
where errors have come from sometimes
you know that can include programming
error
programmer error right they increa
incorrectly index that data frame
um it could be a dependency right
there's a bug and a package that i was
relying on and as
as in the um the steve chang case um it
could also be a systemic cause
so for example you know we were in a
hurry because we needed to get the paper
submitted before
you know blah blah blah
so that helps figure out how can we in
the future avoid errors
okay i'm going to talk now about sharing
so
you know most of our work is paid for by
taxpayers and we owe it to them to
maximize the benefits of
their support we also owe it to our
research subjects to
human or non-human to maximize the
benefits of their participation
and we owe it to the world to maximize
the benefits of the carbon that we're
burning
you know running our super computers so
one really important thing is
is sharing code you know many people are
kind of you know bashful about sharing
their code because they're not
um they're not professional programmers
they're worried that somebody's going to
find a problem with it
the question you might want to ask
yourself is if your code is not good
enough to share then why do you think
it's good enough
to use to publish the results that rely
upon it
and nick barn made this this case nicely
a few years ago
arguing that you know everybody should
publish their code it's it's if it's
good enough to
to use for science is good enough to
publish
now many people including us you know
would publish code
just by giving a link to a github
repository this is from a paper we
published last year
um there's an issue with this right so
imagine that you know
we i we put that link in if somebody
goes here you know
changes have been made to that code
since the paper was published how do
they know exactly which version we used
if we
if they want to reproduce those results
and what if you know ian eisenberg
decides to delete the repository and
those
the code goes away so what we now like
to do is um
share data using a persistent identifier
which basically
provides a link to that material that
guarantees that it's not going to go
away
the you're probably familiar with doi
digital object identifier
it's it's actually very easy to get a
doi for code if you
um if your code is on github and use
this thing called zenodo which is a data
sharing repository that's run by cern
in switzerland um you basically just
sign up for
xenodo login using your github account
and then link your github repository to
your to that you want to
share to that zenodo account and then
anytime you create a release on github
which basically says this is a kind of a
frozen
release of the of the repository
um that will automatically be turned
into a release on
that's shared on zenodo um and that has
a doi
um so even if github were to you know
god forbid go away
those data will still be the sort of the
code will still be there on sunodo for
somebody to
to obtain and then finally you can put
that in your paper so here's from our
recent nature paper we say fully
reproducible code
for all the analyses is available here
at this doi
so it gives you a persistent identifier
that's not going to change or go away
now whenever you share anything it's
important to have a license associated
with it that this basically tells people
what they can do
with the the stuff that you're sharing
in general you want to choose the most
permissive license you can
or the one that's used by your research
community if you work with a bunch of
people who use a particular license it's
probably good to use that one
and people often think that
non-commercial lysing
licensing sounds like a good idea
but it rarely is um and importantly
because
the the meaning of non-commercial is
actually not really clear
i mean it ends up greatly limiting reuse
even by people who
you might want to be able to reuse it so
you have to ask your question
if if if somebody actually violated the
license would you pursue legal action
if not then um then you certainly don't
want to put a non-commercial license
because you're basically
you know wasting your time
now i think we probably all agree that
sharing data uh
is alongside our code is essential for
reproducibility
it's really easy to share data badly um
if you haven't seen this cartoon
data sharing and management snafu in
three acts i would uh
suggest you go to youtube and and search
around for that because it's a pretty
humorous little uh
uh extra normal cartoon about
basically how to share data badly
um so one of the important aspects of um
data sharing is
organizing the data in a way that other
people can easily use it
um and using an accepted standard in
one's research community is the best way
to do that so we've been involved for
the last few years in building something
called the brain imaging data structure
or bids which is a
standard for organizing both the data
and the metadata
of a neuroimaging study and the idea is
like if you
you know if you share your data in that
format then other people can easily use
it
um and if you actually organize your
data in that format
format from the beginning um one
remember that you know
share it you're also sharing your data
with yourself in the future so when you
go back and look at a data set next year
you like you'll be able to understand it
more easily if it's in the
standard format and it also then takes
very little extra work to share the data
if you're
in other domains so for
electrophysiology there's a standard
called
neurodata without borders for
psychological data sets there's an
emerging standard called psycds
so the important thing is to find the
standard that works for your data
and use it it's also important to
version
data right because just as you want to
know exactly what version of the code
was used you know data change people
find errors they
add you know variables and so on um so
one thing you can do you know for
smaller data sets we've used
git and github on some occasions and
one way you can version something on
github is basically to give the
the commit id which is a little hash
that basically refers to a specific
version of the code
again we think it's better to use a
repository that actually provides
uh persistent identifiers so for example
if you want to share
from right data you can upload it to
open neuro and
that will give you for a specific
version of the data set which is like a
snapshot of frozen snapshot of the data
you can get a doi pointing to that
particular version so people can
know exactly what version of the data
set you use for your analyses
now licensing shared data is a little
tricky because the legal status of
data with regard to copyright is
complicated most
most data not really copyrightable but
nonetheless any shared data should
always have a terms of use
which people often kind of call a
license associated with it
so that other people know exactly what
they're allowed to do with the data
we generally prefer the most permissive
uh agreement which is called a public
domain dedication or as often referred
to as a cc0
license which basically allows pretty
much anybody to do
anything they want with it and you know
obviously we
i think we have a community agreement
that if you're going to use someone's
data
you're going to cite that person you
know in in the paper
um so
another thing that we need to be able to
share is the platform i mentioned before
how you know the platform can make a
difference
sharing and code the code and data is
not enough and so we've
begun to focus heavily on the idea of
containerization
for um for sharing platforms um
and the idea behind containerization is
really to
sort of allow you to exactly reproduce
not just the code
but the entire platform that uh
that the the code runs on and so the the
technology that we
and most people are kind of you know
focusing on these days is this thing
called docker
um which is a you know an open
openly available package that basically
allows you to define
a computing environment um that
basically says you know what libraries
and software packages do i need and i
can say what specific versions of them i
want
um that basically defines your platform
for computing and then
you can basically give that
definition to somebody else and they can
recreate that exactly and run the code
in
sort of exactly as close a way as is
computationally possible
modulo things like floating point
weirdness
containers are nice one for like you
know sharing what you've done they also
make it really easy for other people to
run your code so i mentioned fmri prep
which is this pre-processing pipeline
that we've developed
you know if you want to run fmi prep
which is a you know a big
package that requires lots of
dependencies you could install all those
dependencies
install the package run the package
but if you have the docker software
installed which is available for
pretty much every platform this you can
basically run fmri prep
using this single command and what it
will do is go pull
this specific version poldrack fmri prep
20.2.0
specific version of our package from our
um
our repository on what's called docker
hub
and run that thing without you having to
install anything it'll basically grab it
run it uh run that specific version and
um
and you're guaranteed to have it run as
reproducibly as possible
now one challenge is that you can't use
docker on most high performance
computing systems because it requires
root access in order to
to run it but there's a
another package another project called
singularity
that allows you to run containers on
high performance computing systems
um so for example um you know we have a
system at stanford called sherlock
and you know if you have a docker image
you can basically use singularity to run
that docker image
on on the high performance computing
system we found this to be
really handy because you know we run
you know analyses on a number of
different high performance computing
systems some at stanford summit texas
and using this we can get exactly the
same results from
you know software run on very different
systems
okay finally i want to mention the idea
of automation um
and so we try to have our goal as being
to be able to for any particular
workflow
we want to be able to rerun the entire
workflow on a new machine
with a single command right i want to be
able to just put everything on a new
you know server and say go and have it
do
everything give me all the same results
that are exactly the same as i would get
anywhere else
now a simple tool for doing that that's
surprisingly useful is the make
tool in unix where you basically just
set up a make file and
you know if you have like a set of
scripts that you need to run
um you can basically just say make all
and it will go do all those things and
that's for simple stuff
that's what we end up using for more
complicated stuff
um you know there's a number of
different
workflow management packages some that
are specific to neural imaging so the
night pipe
project allows you to basically you know
mix and match
modules from a number of different
software packages
into a single workflow that's actually
the basis for our fmri prep package
there's also some more general uh
workflow management tools
focused on machine learning so apache
airflow metaflow
from i think it's from netflix or a
couple of them
um so but it's definitely important to
be able to automate
everything because that then allows you
to
um to be able to run things
one it's much easier for you if anything
changes you have new code you want to
test
you basically just have one button to
push and everything goes one of the
things that we've started doing is using
our test framework to actually run
analyses so
you know we we've already built testing
right to make sure that the code works
but it's also possible to basically just
put your analyses into a test so
basically say hey i have you know i have
all these 12 analyses i want to run
i'm going to write each of them as a
test and then basically i can just say
hey pi test this directory and it goes
and runs all of those analyses you can
see that in this this is for our recent
narps project
all the image analyses were um were
defined as tests so in this case you
know it goes runs
them takes about 16 minutes to do that
and it tells us hey
all the tests pass which means that none
of the analyses crashed
now one of the benefits of this is that
you can then automate this further
using a tool from software engineering
called continuous integration so
continuous integration is basically a
system that
re-runs all the tests anytime anything
changes in a code repository
so we use this for the darp study
where we you know we had a large code
base
um and obviously we were doing
continuous development on that
each time we made a change to the code
and pushed it
to to github that we set
that to trigger this system called
circle ci
to basically grab the code grab the
docker container that defined the
platform
grab the data that were needed for
running the analyses those were
on zenodo and basically run everything
and tell us ultimately did it succeed
and one of the things you can have it do
is basically save all the results out as
an artifact and now you have
your full analysis run all the the
results saved out that you can basically
just then hand over to somebody
um now you know when we were doing this
circle ci was the
the kind of platform of choice but now
github has its own continuous
integration
system called github actions that is
pretty easy to use and i would recommend
that
okay so why why aren't we there already
why isn't everybody doing all this stuff
right well it's all about incentives um
so first
like you know i've already shown you a
bunch of books and a bunch of new tools
and all this sort of stuff you have to
learn
you know who has time to learn all that
extra stuff
right um it's you know there we have a
limited amount of time
and obviously learning this stuff is
going to take away from other stuff that
you might do
um and this combines with the fact that
there's little incentive for this for
for one to do this sort of stuff this is
what happens if you put it the academic
job market is
into google um and so
you know it's clear now that the the
incentives for
people who are you know early career
researchers are all about
publishing more right not publishing
papers that are more reproducible
simply publishing more papers in fancier
journals and
any time you spend trying to make your
research more reproducible
is almost certainly going to result in
fewer papers per
per amount of time so you know a number
of
us have gotten very interested in you
know what we can do
to um to try to basically align these
incentives and there's currently a
project
um that i've been involved in a little
bit uh run by the national academies
called the round table on aligning
incentives for open science
they're soon going to be putting out a
tool kit that's
largely meant for sort of universities
to um
to you know kind of figure out how can
we
make it so that you know people are
incentivized to
do open and reproducible science um
and finally i want to you know highlight
an idea
that has come about recently you know
udefrith wrote about this
recently in her um in tix but it's
actually an idea that's been around for
at least a decade
john horgan wrote about it you know back
in 2011 this idea of slow science
so udef says fast science is bad for
scientists and bad for science
slow science may actually help us make
faster progress
and john horgan says i've expending i've
expended much of my career heaping
calamity on bad science why am i
so opposed to the slow science movement
here's why i fear that if scientists
really slow down and start publishing
only high quality data and theories and
have been
double and triple checked i won't have
anything left to write about
right meaning that he won't have bad
science to trash on
so just to summarize i've tried to lay
out you know a set of
values principles and practices that i
think together
define how we can move towards not just
you know sort of saying that
reproducibility is important but having
it
be you know central and fundamental to
our
to our research culture in neuroscience
and in data science more generally
so finally i want to thank my lab this
is this is my lab circa
2020 the way that we've been seeing each
other
and mentioned that we've just started a
new center at stanford as part of the
data science institute
called the center for open and
reproducible science or cores which is
going to be
developing infrastructure and um
and tools to help people do open science
um so with that i will stop and be happy
to take questions
thank you so much russ what a lot to
think about in terms of
i'm just thinking of the picture in my
head of this layer cake
of code development github data
workflows
um continuous integration and all of
this is being this
infrastructure for reproducible science
um you made a point of talking about
this is the
the sources of potential places
where reproducibility is probably really
important and then it's
in terms of the variations between
computer systems whether you know
big indian little indian problems used
to be the bane of our existence
um software errors and we've seen
several of those crop up
in particular in neuro imaging for
example where
statements about probability of results
happening was improperly reported
software libraries they change all the
time you got to recompile stuff and and
all that
and you mentioned about um the
portability
of the the methodologies um their
provenance
and best practice i mean how can we do a
better job of making sure that all of
those things
you touched on this in terms of peer
reviewed publication
what do the journals think of all this
um i know you're as a journal editor
yourself
um this must come up what do journals
think about this
process that people need to go through
um i think it it's interesting question
right i think it varies across journals
clearly you know some journals are
i think data sharing has been the you
know the probably the most prominent
place where this has come up and there's
a number of uh journals that are either
requiring data sharing like um
you know like plus one or that are
trying to incentivize it by for example
giving badges
like you know the psychological science
does um
and they you know you can also have
badges for things like you know
materials and code sharing
um i think that the challenge for the
you know nature
the nature journals have also done some
various experiments like you know having
people
upload things to code ocean um
and um and i think that you know they're
still sort of struggling with
particularly how to manage the
review process around you know stuff
that's you know research objects beyond
the paper right because historically
we've just reviewed the paper
um but um but you know it's clear to me
having been
you know for example i reviewed one
paper a few years ago
where it was in a journal where they
shared the data
and i it was you know i looked closely
at the data and i realized hey there's a
problem with what you've done the
results are probably due to an artifact
here rather than
due to a real result um
and that paper you know may well have
gotten published had they not shared the
code and
and we you've been able to see that but
that takes a lot of work
on the reviewers part right viewers are
already it's already hard to find
reviewers reviewers are already strapped
for time
and so expecting them to do this is
challenging
um you know some journals have like
statistical editors who will actually
look at the statistical
stuff but that doesn't mean that they're
able to like go in and actually run the
code obviously if it's if it's easily
runnable
like if it's you know containerized or
if it's in a you know in something like
one of these sort of online platforms
like binder or something like that or
code ocean
then that makes it a lot easier for
people to do but you know it requires
that the
the reviewers have expertise in it so i
think that's the big challenge i think
the
the the journals many of the journals
you know are many of the top journals at
least
are very attuned to the issues they just
i think don't know how to deal with
the challenges of actually getting
people to review the code and the data
yeah one you've mentioned a number of
different
resources um that's places where people
can share code
how they can link it up for example with
the circle ci thing i wasn't familiar
with and that sounds really interesting
um but it seems like not a day goes by
at least from my perspective
there isn't some other new thing that i
should be attending to for how i should
share my data my code my
results and uh how do it get that
some of them are brand new and some of
them have a big huge community around
them for example like the galaxy
people just seem to like that's just
caught fire across the planet
how do you kind of filter these how do
you know when something
is something you're going to go and tack
your flag to in terms of resources for
trying to make things reproducible yeah
i mean i try not to be a super early
adopter
me either and i've been burned in some
ways like you know
allow other people to kind of do the
exploration and then i can exploit once
they've found something so
you know what i try to do is like look
at what other look at what the
like you know the early adopters in my
particular field are doing so for
example
you know we use nypi like you know
galaxy's taken off in a lot of areas it
hasn't really taken off in neuro imaging
as far as i could tell
um and that's you know in large part
because there are other
you know um there are other sort of
tools like nypipe that i think have
become
you know sort of more popular um and to
the degree that there's a domain
specific tool or a field specific tool i
usually
kind of you know tend towards those um
you know i so i think part of this is
about like you know really keeping your
ear to the ground
uh in terms of like what the you know
like what the
the people at the bleeding edge are
doing and then you know
letting them kind of smooth things out a
bit so waiting you know if they're still
like if you hear them talking about you
know
circle ci and they're still talking
about it six months later
that's probably a good sign that's a
good sign that it actually sort of hung
around yeah because i you know there are
certain
there's certain early adopter people who
i won't name and i feel like every time
i have a conversation
with with them i have to learn like 12
new acronyms
right because there's all these new new
projects they're talking about
and and i try to i try to let them
smooth that over for me
i i i go through that same process
myself it's just trying
i just try to keep up um now
i want to hear a little more about your
kind of personal
journey here of how you started to
become an advocate for studying
reproducibility in neuroscience um
how you establish this in your
laboratory and what advice you might
have for young researchers who are just
really getting started building
laboratory how do you establish
and get this culture underway in their
laboratories
yeah um so i got you know i so
you know i grew up as kind of an open
source software
advocate i guess and so you know even at
the beginning of my career
i was you know sharing code i had a back
around like 2000 or so we had this
spm roi toolbox that you could use for
like extracting data from spm analyses
that we shared openly so i've always
been an advocate for for kind of you
know
code sharing and and openness um
and i think that's just kind of a
philosophical thing you know around how
i think science should work
the reproducibility stuff i became much
more attuned to
around 2008 there was a um
a paper that when it was initially
floated was titled voodoo correlations
in social neuroscience it ended up
with a different name but i saw the
pre-print
and you know it highlighted this issue
of of a practice that people were doing
in the neuro-imaging literature was
basically double dipping
um with roi analyses and you know
realized that we had done that in some
of our papers
um even though we weren't named you know
in that in the
the paper by edwin colleagues um and so
started really trying to like you know
dig in
dig more into the the nature of our
methods
and then you know soon thereafter came
about
the the whole quote unquote
reproducibility crisis that kind of
started in psychology
um and and that
you know highlighting issues around like
you know questionable research practices
p hacking that sort of stuff and and
again you know it got me realized that
you know many of the things that they
were showing
to be problematic were things that
pretty much every neuroimaging lab
was doing and so that you know
those things really got me to start
rethinking how we do science
um and so when i moved to stanford
i was lucky enough to have two things
happen one was chris gorgolowski
joined my lab as a postdoc he's now
moved on to google
um but you know he and i kind of were
able to build we're able to get a large
grant from the arnold foundation
and build this um what we call the
center for reproducible neuroscience
which was the
the the home of the open neuro project
we had started sharing data back around
2010 as part of this open fmri project
and then open neuro was kind of like the
next generation of that
um and i you know obviously jack your
your early work was really inspiring
around
you know data sharing and you know when
it
when it finally really sort of took off
around 2010
you know a lot of people were sharing
wrestling data we wanted to be in the
business of sharing
uh tasks fmri data in particular um and
so
you know built some infrastructure
around that um and then
you know more recently i've been
focusing on bids as a as an essential
part of the infrastructure for data
sharing
so that's a long-winded way of kind of
talking about
uh you know how i got here how have i
established a culture of code
reproducibility in my lab
um one is i think you know
highlighting the highlighting the
the need to be thoughtful and the need
to kind of you know think about
uh how one writes code and having you
know i think that you know
it's easy to just kind of write code and
assume that it works right if you don't
see any problems you assume that it
worked and i try to
you know more than anything instill this
sort of reflective
philosophy about like you know the fact
that
i i wrote a blog post a few years ago
talking about the principle of assumed
error
this idea that like if you if you have
an analysis that quote-unquote works
that you should basically assume you've
done something wrong
and um try to figure out what that might
be and you know we've had we've had
interesting cases in the lab where
you know one of the post-docs had a
result that looked really good
um but had for some reason like had a
suspicion that something funny might be
going on and
it took this person at least a month of
like digging around off and on
to find the error that they had made in
the code that when it was fixed the
result went away
and this i mean and this speaks to the
kind of cost of reproducibility i wrote
a piece in neuron last year called the
cost of reproducibility
right if you work that way you're gonna
have fewer papers period
right this person probably could have
published a perfectly good paper on this
interesting result
in a good journal that would have
probably never been
uncovered because people are so you know
unlikely to actually try to replicate
any particular
findings or like dig through
code even if the code was shared it's
unlikely anybody would have put
put in the work to find that problem
this is a person whose you know
career-wise false discovery rate is
going to be low right
there it's a person whose work you can
trust
um but unfortunately you know that that
kind of trust is not the thing that gets
you
jobs right or gets you tender oh um
so people you know my trainees publish
relatively little compared to other labs
like i had two
phds recently who both walked out with
like one
you know they had a few like smaller
papers but one kind of big paper
one was a pnas paper one was a nature
communications paper so i think they
were high impact papers
but they aren't published they don't
have these long cds because they're not
like cranking things out if you
kind of you know have a a factory that
cares less about replication
um and that's a to these people i think
that um you know ultimately
you know they've been able to go on and
and do good things in their careers
um but um but it you know speaks to one
of the one of the questions is there
like you know
this it one can get dinged for not being
productive now i should say you know i
there are people i know um in the field
who have always published relatively
little
um but when they publish something it's
really good
um and so i think it's you know there's
there's room for those
type of people but it's it can be hard
to it can be hard to get
the job as that sort of person once you
have the job it's
i think people can get tenured you know
if they can show that hey i publish one
paper a year but it's a really good
paper
rather than publishing you know five
papers a year and having them all just
kind of be you know
sort of factory stuff um but it's a
i think the only way to fix this issue
is by
i think there's there's it has to happen
from two directions one is changing from
the top
right that university presidents and
provosts
department chairs you know senior
faculty all need to change the way
they think about like how we judge
people for
hiring promotion and tenure
and at the same time we do pressure from
below where you know fields
need to push to you know push everybody
in that particular discipline to do open
science and the way that i think for
example the
the you know oh the human brain mapping
organization has it's interesting that
you know
i remember a relatively you know
famous senior person a few years ago
complaining
at an ohbm meeting that you know that
the open science
zealots had taken over the organization
fast forward five years and this person
is now one of the biggest advocates for
open science
so that you know that kind of change can
happen pretty quickly when there's a lot
of pressure from the bottom
um but i think we also need the pressure
from the top uh
yeah i agree uh well i think with that's
a great
a place to end and i want to thank you
dr polderak for
for sharing your your thoughts and uh
your your
ideas about reproducible science about
how to implement it and uh tools for so
doing
and sharing us with your personal story
and ideas about how to
implement this in in the laboratories of
the young investigators who are joining
us today
um so thank you once again thank you to
everybody who joined us
um everybody have a great weekend and
we'll see you next week
for our next installment in this seminar
series so thank you everyone
take care all right thanks bile